♪
>> Jesse: REMEMBER HOW GREAT
HIGH SCHOOL WAS?
FULL OF FUNNY PEOPLE.
GOOD TIME, MAYBE A FEW PARTIES.
YOU LEARN SOME IMPORTANT THINGS
ABOUT YOURSELF.
YOU'RE INCREDIBLY IMMATURE AND
YOU KNOW NEXT TO NOTHING.
YOU INSIST YOU ARE ALWAYS RIGHT
NO MATTER WHAT AND REFUSE TO
LISTEN TO ANYBODY ELSE'S
OPINION.
IN REALITY, YOU ARE AN IDIOT.
IT'S NOT THE WONDER YEARS.
IT'S THE BLUNDER YEARS.
YOU WEAR OBNOXIOUS CLOTHING EVEN
THOUGH IT LOOKS TERRIBLE.
BUT YOU CAN'T SEE IT AT THE
TIME.
STRANGE THINGS.
I SURE DID.
AND YOU END WITH FRIENDS LIKE
THESE TROUBLE MAKERS.
BUEHRLE, BUEHRLE.
BUEHRLE.
>> Bret: BUT WHEN YOU GROW UP
AND BECOME AN ADULT YOU LOOK
BACK ON THOSE DAYS AND LAUGH AT
HOW FOOLISH YOU WERE.
YOUR CLOTHES, YOUR HAIR, YOUR
FRIENDS, YOU REALIZE YOU WERE
COMPLETELY WRONG ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS ACTED LIKE
CHILDREN.
PUSHING ASININE POLICIES HURT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PRETENDING LIKE THEY KNOW BEST
WHEN THEIR FOOLISHNESS WAS
COMPLETELY OBVIOUS.
THEY SUPPORTED RIOTS.
WORSHIPPED WOKENESS.
THE SQUAD DEMOCRATIC HOOD
ORNAMENT.
RECOGNIZING THEIR MISTAKES AND
WHEN I SAY ADULTS, I REALLY MEAN
POLLSTERS.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM
POLITICO, INTERNAL POLLING BY
HOUSE DEMOCRATS SHOWED THEM WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG.
THEY ARE UNLIKEABLE AND OUT OF
TOUCH.
WITH THE REPORT HIGHLIGHTING THE
FACT THAT SOME BATTLEGROUND
VOTERS THINK THE PARTY IS
PREACHY.
JUDGMENTAL, AND FOCUSED ON
CULTURE WARS, WHO COULD HAVE
GUESSED THAT THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN DOESN'T WANT TO SEE
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE AUDITIONING
TO BE A SOCIAL LITE ON THE RED
CARPET OR THAT VOTERS DIDN'T
WANT TO BE JUDGED FOR BACKING
THE BLUE DURING A CRIME WAVE.
BUT DON'T WORRY, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT, TOO.
THE POLITICO PIECE GOES ON TO
SAY THAT WHEN FACED WITH A
DEFUND THE POLICE ATTACK FOR
INSTANCE REITERATE SUPPORT FOR
POLICE.
ON IMMIGRATION THEY SAID
DEMOCRATS SHOULD DENY SUPPORT
FOR OPEN BORDERS OR AMNESTY.
AND TALK ABOUT THEIR EFFORTS TO
KEEP THE BORDER SAFE.
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY NEED POLLING
TO TELL THEM THE OBVIOUS
AMERICAN PEOPLE SUPPORT POLICE
AND OPEN BORDERS.
DENY THE LIE AND PRETEND LIKE
THAT'S BEEN THEIR POSITION ALL
ALONG.
WE ARE NOT STUPID.
WE KNOW THEY SPENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS SLANDERING POLICE, CALLING
THEM RACIST.
DEFUNDING THEM, BAILING OUT
THEIR ATTACKERS AND MAKING THEIR
JOBS HARDER WITH THESE SOFT ON
CRIME D.A.s.
JUST LISTEN TO THEM SAY IT FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO DEFUND
BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE AND
START ANEW.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE REDUCTION
OF OUR BUDGET AND DEFUNDING THE
NYPD BUDGET.
>> YES, I SUPPORT THE DEFUND
MOVEMENT BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT
THE INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN DIVESTED.
>> I AM FOR DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
>> Jesse: PRO-CRIME MESSAGES
LIKE THIS FILLED THE STREETS
WITH BLOOD.
DEMOCRATS WERE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE YOU AND YOUR SAFETY TO
PUSH THEIR CULTURE WARS.
AND THEY WANT TO KNOW WHY THE
PEOPLE ARE REJECTING THEIR
MESSAGE?
ISN'T IT OBVIOUS?
PEOPLE ARE GETTING HURT.
FINANCIALLY AND PHYSICALLY NOW
DEMOCRATS COOKING UP ALIBI
MIDTERMS EVEN THOUGH
FINGERPRINTS ARE ALL OVER THE
WOUNDS.
RATHER THAN FOCUS ON REAL ISSUES
LIKE THE CHAOS AT THE BORDER OR
OUT OF CONTROL INFLATION.
THEY WANTED TO MAKE YOUR CHILD
FEEL LIKE A RACIST AND CALL YOU
A RACIST.
FOR JUST CARING ABOUT.
>> I'M NOT SCHOOLS AND TAKE OUT
AND MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
I DON'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD BE
TELLING SCHOOLS WHAT THEY SHOULD
TEACH.
>> I DON'T THINK WE WOULD THINK
WE BELIEVE THAT EDUCATING THE
YOUTH AND NEXT LEADERS -- THE
FUTURE LEADERS OF THE COUNTRY ON
SYSTEMIC RACISM IS
INDOCTRINATION.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE USING THESE
WORDS LIKE CRITICAL RACE THEORY,
WHICH, AGAIN, IS A LAW SCHOOL
CURRICULA THAT IS NOT EVEN
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS.
AND THEIR ARGUMENT IS WELL SOME
TEACHERS MAY BE EXPOSED TO IT
OH, WOW, SO YOUR CHILD'S TEACHER
IS NOT -- IS ANTI-RACIST AND IS
ACTUALLY FLUENT IN HOW TO
DISMANTLE RACISM IN THE DYNAMICS
OF RACISM IN A CLASSROOM.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
TEACHER SHOULD KNOW HOW TO DO.
>> Jesse: CRITICAL RACE THEORY,
DEFUND THE POLICE, THIS IS WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE STOOD FOR.
IT'S A LOSING MESSAGE.
ASK TERRY McAULIFFE IN
VIRGINIA.
DEMOCRATS REJECTED AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
ALL ACROSS AMERICA IN 2021.
SO WHAT'S THEIR PLAN FOR THE
MIDTERMS.
PUSH MORE LIES.
THE POLITICO REPORT GOES ON TO
SAY THIS.
DEMOCRATS NEED TO DEMONSTRATE
THEY FULLY UNDERSTAND AND CARE
ABOUT STRESSORS IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
AND FOCUS ON THE ISSUES WITHOUT
STOKING DIVISIVE CULTURAL
DEBATES.
GOT IT DEMOCRATS NEED TO IGNORE
ALL THEIR FAILURES ON CRIME,
COVID INFLATION AND IMMIGRATION
AND DO A BETTER JOB PRETENDING
LIKE THEY ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
SOMETHING.
WE KNOW THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT ONE
THING, ACTUALLY.
AND IT'S THIS.
>> TODAY DEMOCRACY FACES A NEW
THREAT, THE JANUARY 6TH ATTACK
ON THE U.S. CAPITOL WAS ONE OF
THE DARKEST DAYS IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
JANUARY 6TH VIOLENT INSURRECTION
AND ATTACK OBJECT CITADEL OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> WHEN AN ANGRY VIOLENT MOB
STAGED AN INSURRECTION ON
JANUARY 6TH AND DESECRATED OUR
CAPITOL THE TEMPLE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IT WAS NOT JUST AN
ATTACK ON THE BUILDING.
IT WAS AN ATTACK ON OUR REPUBLIC
ITSELF.
>> DEMOCRATS KNOW MORE ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH THAN THEY KNOW ABOUT
THE PRICE OF GAS.
ASK THEM HOW MANY PEOPLE STORMED
THE CAPITOL THAT DAY AND THEY
WILL TELL YOU.
ASK THEM HOW MANY ILLEGAL ALIENS
CROSSED THE BORDER?
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT DATE,
JANUARY 6TH THAN AMERICA'S
MURDER RATE.
SO, THE NEW MESSAGE ABOUT
COMPASSION AND HOW THEY SUPPORT
THIS AND THAT.
THIS ISN'T BECAUSE THEY HAVE
DONE SOME SOUL SEARCHING.
THIS ISN'T THEM RECKONING WITH
DANGEROUS POLICIES.
JUST A PREPACKAGED FOCUS GROUP
TESTED MESSAGE THAT THEY'RE
USING TO HIDE THEIR RADICAL
AGENDA.
JUST UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION.
THEN THEY TURN BACK INTO KARL
MARX.
DEMOCRATS TREAT VOTERS LIKE
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE THE SNEAKY ONES.
WE'LL CAN'T TAKE OUR EYES OFF
THEM FOR A SECOND OR THEY WILL
GET US ALL IN TROUBLE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING
DRESS-UP.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY ARE ABOUT
TO BE PUNISHED FOR WHO THEY
REALLY ARE EVEN VOTERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF THE
WOKE B.S., WHICH IS A PRETTY
ENCOURAGING SIGN FOR US.
IF THEY CAN'T WIN WITH A HOME
FIELD ADVANTAGE LIKE THAT, HOW
CAN THEY EXPECT TO TAKE PEOPLE
DOWN IN BATTLEGROUND STATES?
BUT THEY HAVE NOBODY TO BLAME
BUT THEMSELVES.
CHILDREN ACROSS THE CITY WERE
TRAPPED IN THEIR HOMES DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
AS CLASSROOM DOORS REMAIN
SHUTTERED THANKS TO THE STUPID
SCHOOL BOARD.
RATHER THAN TRY TO MITIGATE THE
EXPLODING ADOLESCENT MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
THE BOARD DECIDED THIS WAS A
GREAT TIME TO RENAME SOME
SCHOOLS.
THEY ATTACKED SCHOOLS NAMED FOR
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND ABE
LINCOLN.
HALF OF THE FACES ON MOUNT
RUSHMORE.
AND ARGUABLY AMERICA'S TWO
GREATEST PRESIDENTS.
WHILE THEIR STUDENTS WERE GLUED
TO A COMPUTER SCREEN INSTEAD OF
LEARNING IN ALSO A THROUGHOUT
CHICKENS HAVE COME HOME TO
ROOST.
LAST NIGHT THE OVERWHELMINGLY
LIBERAL CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
VOTED TO RECALL THREE BOARD
MEMBERS INCLUDING THE BOARD'S
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT.
PARENTS AND VOTERS THERE SENT A
CLEAR MESSAGE TO THOSE IN POWER.
WE WILL NOT STAY QUIET AS YOU
PUT PROGRESSIVE POLITICS AHEAD
OF OUR CHILDREN.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A CHANGE IN
THE EQUILLIBRUM IN THE LANDSCAPE
OF WHO IS BEING HEARD, WHO IS AT
THE TABLE.
THIS HAS SHOWN THAT PARENTS
CAN'T BE IGNORED ANY LONGER.
>> CHANNEL FRUSTRATION SOMETHING
THAT LEAD [INAUDIBLE]
>> THERE WERE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
ARE UPSET AT THE BOARD BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT LISTENING.
>>
>> Jesse: THE PEOPLE OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE SPOKEN UP.
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE REST
OF AMERICA.
THE MIDTERMS WILL BE HERE SOONER
THAN YOU THINK.
WE NEED YOU TO STAND UP AND MAKE
SURE YOUR VOICE IS HEARD.
GET INVOLVED IN YOUR LOCAL RACE,
VOLUNTEER, DO A PHONEBACK, SOME
CANVASSING, WHATEVER IT TAKES.
BECAUSE, LIKE THE SAYING GOES,